what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like there
has been a big change with Disney as the
CEO or I should say the former CEO now
Bob chapek has departed from the company
and he will be replaced by his
predecessor Bob Iger this definitely
comes as quite a shock although from the
outside looking in it did seem like a
lot of people at Disney didn't exactly
agree with some things that Bob chapek
was doing we'll get to that in just a
bit but I'm sure people are thinking
will this affect Marvel Studios Star
Wars and everything else under the belt
of Disney and I think it is going to and
I think it is going to in a positive way
especially when it comes to Disney plus
now Disney has released one official
statement and Bob Iger who is now the
CEO of Disney has released a statement
himself basically Bob Iger statement was
thanking everybody the first paragraph
reads it is with an incredible sense of
gratitude and humility and I must admit
a bit of Amazement that I write to you
this evening with the news that I am
returning to the Walt Disney Company as
chief executive officer he then
congratulates the employees and cast
members for all the success that they
have had at Disney and that Disney has
had over the past couple of years since
he's been gone then he says they will
hear more from him tomorrow and in the
following days and weeks to come now
here is Disney's official statement they
say we think Bob chapek for his service
to Disney over his long career including
navigating the company through the
unprecedented challenges of the pandemic
the board has concluded that as Disney
embarks on an increasingly complex
period of Industry transformation Bob
Iger is uniquely situated to lead the
company through this pivotal period so
basically this pretty much sounds like
Disney's board of directors fired Bob
chabic now when Bob chapek first came on
him and Bob Iger would work together Bob
Iger would kind of you know show him the
robes help him get situated and rumors
had it that they didn't exactly agree
with a lot and see eye to eye there were
also other rumors that suggested a lot
of people at Disney didn't see eye to
eye with him as well so it doesn't
exactly come as a huge shock but here's
what Bob Iger has to do with it Disney
released the statement stating Iger has
agreed to serve as Disney's CEO for two
years with a mandate from the board to
set the Strategic direction for renewed
growth and to work closely with the
board in developing a successor to lead
the company at the completion of his
term so it seems like they were unhappy
with the way things have been over the
past few years they brought Bob Iger
back because he did an incredible job
they want him to be CEO for two years
and they also want him to find and train
a successor now again how will this
affect Marvel Studios well I think it's
going to affect Disney plus a lot of
people have expressed that phase 4 of
the MCU has kind of been the worst phase
out of all the phases this is really
hard to say and also really hard to
judge because it's the first phase where
we have Disney Plus shows not just
movies however it does seem like Marvel
Studios is doing a lot we went from
having two to three movies a year to
having four movies a year plus five six
seven who knows how many Disney Plus
shows and then of course specials as
well this is a lot and we've heard
rumors and reports that the employees
aren't exactly getting treated the best
they're getting overworked and they're
underpaid and some have said that the
quality of the Disney Plus shows isn't
really there in some shows it is
particularly lacking and even I can
admit that the CGI and some of these
shows and the writing in some of these
shows hasn't exactly been the best right
now we're unclear on how this change
will affect Marvel Studios but I'm
assuming if it is going to have an
effect it'll be on the frequency that
Marvel releases shows I'm assuming that
the change would be there going to
release less Disney Plus shows and focus
more on quality and not quantity that's
the change I think we'll see I don't
think we're gonna see anything else
Marvel Studios is still doing really
really well and of course Kevin feige is
still the president of Marvel Studios
however we're not sure if Disney had a
requirement for them to do a certain
amount of shows and movies per year and
that's why they upped it if that was the
case perhaps Bob Iger can come in and
say hey we're not going to do that
there's no quota we're just going to
focus on making great movies and making
great shows which I hope is something
that actually happens again it's really
hard to judge phase four because it's
completely new it's brand new nothing
has been done like this before by Marvel
Studios they added new shows that
connected to the MCU that's a big
Venture and I think they've done a
pretty good job so far yes some things
could have been better but maybe they're
about to get better right now so let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below what do you think do
you think Marvel Studios will be
affected by this and do you think it'll
be good or bad don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to stay up to date
on all things relating to the MCU for
live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf